les transports encore avec la suite de
la grande aventure industrielle de
l'a380 le premier tronçon du géant est
passé sans encombre sous le pont de
pierre à bordeaux sur la garonne
des centaines de bordelais s'étaient
massées sur les quais dalit bazié
bernard bonne arme sur place le pari
d'airbus en train de se réaliser l'a380
géant peut bel et bien passer sous le
pont de pierre de bordeaux le principal
obstacle entre hambourg lieu de
production et toulouse site d'assemblage
on va monter crescendo
jusqu'à faire ça une fois par semaine à
transporter un avion par semaine ce qui
veut dire minimum quatre passages de bar
je pense à chaque passage la barge ne
dispose que de quelques minutes où sont
réunies les conditions idéales de marée
et de vents
le pilote aujourd'hui a dû patienter
plus de trois quarts d'heure ce qui est
particulièrement important c'est les
cellules coefficients de marée la météo
peut évoluer on verra avant le passage
comme la procédure le prévoit
tout au long du trajet l'avion géant à
son public à bordeaux bien sûr mais
aussi à langon petite ville de gironde
où les morceaux de fuselage sont
débarqués les habitants se presto
mais déjà la la remorque la technique
sortir l'avion comme ça sur une remorque
technique il fait des amis aux états
unis je leur envoie de temps d'amener
email informations voir qu'il ya pas que
boeing il existe une remorque géante
radiocommandés vient chercher le
fuselage l'avion rejoindra toulouse en
camion ce long périple depuis hambourg
coûte 1 % du prix de l'avion environ 2
millions d'euros